[Music]
[Applause]
Well, my mission as a woman and as an
athlete, in this case a footballer, in the
end, what I want is to continue working
and continue fighting so that the girls
of today,
the girls that come from behind,
have what  that we didn't have in its
day and above all because I wanted to
transmit women's soccer to continue to
grow
[Music]
I really believe that not only have we
been through many challenges obviously
when we were little unfortunately it
was impossible for a player or a girl to
want to play soccer on  everything with
boys I think that today a
lot of progress is being made in all this day after
day we have our rights as
women to play soccer and to do
many other things and I think that in the
end we are in a good position if
we continue fighting to improve  but
above all knowing that the road has been
long but that we are achieving
things
[Music]
that I would not say to all
those people at the end  he women girls boys to
all those who have to fight for
their dreams that in the end life puts
obstacles and they have to continue towards
them is to tell them to never
give up to continue that in the end life is
that not to fall and get up and look
up and above all because the problem that
I have been following since I got sick and I want it to
be public everywhere in the end is
that no one regrets being brave and
I say that from the bottom of my heart that is true from
time to time when everything is put into  your
way
[Music]
[Applause]
why
[Music]